our sales receive signal from the nearby
cells or something far apart by
endocrine or paracrine or autocrine
fashion where ligands received the
signal and there are certain second
messenger molecules in the cytoplasm
which conveyed a signal and transduce
into the nucleus the headquarters of the
cell and in the nucleus the signal is
red and the necessary action is taken in
terms of gene transcription or several
other changes inside the cell now this
second messenger system plays an impact
important role to relay the signal that
is received by the cells and another
receptor so in this video we'll talk
about one such second messenger molecule
which was discovered the earliest the
cyclic a MP now cyclic a MP is a cyclic
variant of ATP now wonder why ATP cannot
be a cyclic if ATP cannot be a second
messenger now APB is produced by the
cell for many purposes for energy
purposes and many other purposes now if
ATP works like a selective second
messenger signal then the cell might
have gone confused so it's important to
produce and easy to produce a cyclic
variant of ATP which is unique and which
could be read whose concentration could
be read by several mechanisms inside the
cell to decode the signals that is
received in the receptor level so let's
just look at it in details so when the
ligand binds to the receptor and most of
the cases these receptors are g-protein
coupled receptors in this example a
g-protein coupled receptor is shown it
activates the g-protein associated with
the G PCR which in turns activates
adenylate cyclase now adenylate cyclase
converts ATP to cyclic in mp and thus
cyclic a MP is generated and works like
a second messenger
cyclic EMP can bind to protein kinase a
in this case now protein kinase a is a
kinase which has two regulatory domains
and two catalytic domains now catalytic
domains in the normal situation are
inactivated
but when cyclic a MP binds the
regulatory domain the catalytic domains
are freed from this complex and the
catalytic domain are free to migrate
into the nucleus into the nucleus
catalytic domain of protein kinase a
interacts with crib and creb binding
protein CBP they recruit transcriptional
activators and thereby help in
transcribing specific target genes and
these target genes ranges from several
metabolic products to ion channels to
cytoskeletal elements and many other
things so now we understand how cyclic
AMP II can read the signal can relay the
signal which is received in the receptor
end and can relay that bias certain
other modulators into the nucleus so
this relaying function was very
important because earlier days the
relaying function it's hard to
conceptualize there are some
intermediate molecules which is
functioning like a relay I'll come to
that in a moment now it has been seen
that with neuronal activity there is an
increase in cyclic AMP e level and that
is important for formation of long term
memories researchers like Eric Kandel
has shown that in Aplysia in order to
convert short-term memory to long-term
memory cyclic AMP II elevation and CREB
mediated transcription is important not
only that fly mutants which are in which
cyclic production cyclic AMP II
production is applicated they are their
learning performance decreased
dramatically suggesting its role in
learning and memory now cyclic AMP II
has immense importance but have you ever
wondered that how did scientists figure
out that cyclic AMP II could work like a
second messenger now initially when
people were trying to find the mechanism
of hormonal action
they thought the receptor has its own
enzymatic activity that is giving rise
to the downstream signaling nobody
thought of one relay but there was one
researcher known as our Sutherland who
received Nobel Prize in 1971 for his
discoveries related to mechanism of
hormone action especially epinephrine so
our Sutherland worked on hormonal
mechanism specifically epinephrine how a
penofin works at a molecular level so he
showed that that how nearby cells can
secrete epinephrine and that can invoke
signal inside the cell and how that can
work via cyclic EMP so for this work he
got a Nobel Prize in 1971 so our
Sutherland moved to Utah University of
Washington where he was in the lab of
Carl and Gerta Cory in their lab our
Sutherland found out that the hormone
epinephrine or adrenaline can lead to
breakdown of glycogen into glucose also
he found out that glycogen phosphorylase
is the terminal enzyme which is
responsible for this kind of process now
he asked a important question that in
order to ask the question he knew that
the glycogenolysis is happening in the
liver so he took out mouse liver now he
separated the two fractions a membrane
fraction and a cytoplasmic fraction now
these mines were well fed so they don't
need any reason to break down glycogen
into glucose unless and until a signal
is inducing to do so so definitely he
expect that in the membrane in the
membrane component the receptor or
anything the trans receptor molecules
could be there and in the cytoplasmic
fraction the enzymatic components would
be there now what he did is he put
epinephrine in the membrane component
now epinephrine might result in
production of some legendaries second
messengers right now what in order to
Stan without any second messenger is
generated and the second messenger is
the one who is conveying the message to
downstream targets in order to perform
any physiological changes he did another
experiment where he charged this
solution with epinephrine addition and
then filtered out this solution and put
this solution into the cytoplasmic
fraction now when he put the solution
into the cytoplasmic fraction he acid
for glycogen phosphorylase activity
now if glycogen phosphorylase activities
unaltered then it is evident that no
site cytosolic second messenger or any
relay molecule is produced and it it
might might not evoke any signal and it
might not convey the message that is
received in the membrane fraction by a
epinephrine addition right but when he
did this experiment before and after
addition of the epinephrine activated
membrane fraction he found asker
addition of the epinephrine activated
membrane fraction the phosphorylase
activity dramatically increased that
suggested there is a diffusible molecule
in the cytoplasm which can work like a
relay signal so the conversion increase
in sub phosphorylation activity it's not
an intrinsic property of the membrane
receptor there are relay molecules
inside that and he wandered a long time
that what could be this relay molecule
biochemical analysis has shown this
relay molecule turned out to be cyclic
AM P due to his work now we know when we
have a need of rapid muscle movement or
any other kind of job then adrenaline is
secreted adrenaline bind to a drill and
beta adrenergic receptor which activates
qi protein and indeed the g protein
activates adenylate cyclase to produce
cyclic GMP and this cyclic AMP e
activates protein kinase a now in the
liver cell protein kinase a does
important function protein kinase a
activates phosphorylase kinase and
phosphorylase kinase active activates
the enzyme phosphorylase
this phosphorylase is the terminal
enzyme which can break down glycogen
into glucose so this is the
glycogenolysis process which was
entirely discovered after the discovery
of cyclic GMP as a second messenger and
the work from our wing Sutherland R
Sutherland right so if we understand
that how second messenger could work and
how cell read out the second hidden
messages inside the second messenger we
would get a deeper insight how signaling
mechanism work so if you liked this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe to my
channel in order to get notification
frequently just hit the bell icon and if
you have any questions specifically
please mention in the comment section
okay bye